-Now, you guys
are obviously super close.
I have been around both of you,
and it's just --
You work so well off each other.
But I want to see how close
you guys actually are.
With that in mind, it is time
for the Father-Son Challenge.
-♪ "Tonight Show" ♪
♪ Father-Son Challenge ♪
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, so here's how it works.
One of you will --
-[ Laughs ]
-One of you will mute your audio
while the other one answers...
-He's so happy!
-...a question about you.
And then you'll unmute, and
we'll see if they were correct.
If your answer matches,
you get a point.
You ready for this?
-Yes.
-All right, Lin,
can you please mute your audio?
-Yes, sir.
One sec.
-All right.
Luis, here's the question.
Okay?
-Yes.
-What was Lin's dream job
when he was a kid?
-He wanted to be a filmmaker.
And he always walked around
with a camera
and filmed figurines
and filmed anything
he could get his hands on.
-I was gonna say that.
I would say that
or a rock star or something.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, yes, all right.
That's good.
Okay, good.
That's really -- okay.
All right, Lin, you hit unmute.
Good.
That was my signal for unmute.
It was a lot of hand-flapping.
[ Laughter ]
-Flapping hands.
You're a star!
-I could be your adopted son
if you want to.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
Lin, the question was,
what was your dream job
when you were a kid?
-Oh, I wanted to make movies.
I wanted to be Steven Spielberg
when I was a kid.
[ Ding! ]
Hey!
-[ Laughs ]
-Everyone knows that.
-That is fantastic.
That's so good.
Okay.
Luis, you're up.
Please mute your audio.
-[ Laughs ]
-All right. Now he's muted.
All right, good.
-Yeah.
-Good, he's muted.
Okay, good.
He can't hear us, but we can
still hear him weirdly.
His mic is on.
Okay. So, here we go.
Ready?
Lin, what is your dad's
go-to karaoke song?
-Oh.
Um...
It's either --
Can I give you two?
-Yep.
-It's either, "I've Had
the Time of My Life"...
-[ Laughs ]
-He played that song
in our Subaru a solid year.
And I just wanted to hear
"Be My Baby,"
which was the next track on
the "Dirty Dancing" soundtrack.
He would just hit rewind,
play it again.
That or, it's probably, like,
"Greatest Showman."
[ Laughs ] It's probably
"This is the Greatest Show."
-Really?
-He's like a --
He's a "Greatest Showman's" fan.
He's got a red jacket
and everything.
-No way.
-Yeah.
-I love that.
I was gonna say --
I was gonna say
"Sound of Music."
-Oh, yeah.
That's entirely possible, too.
-[ Laughs ]
-I never had a chance
at another living.
It was always
gonna be show tunes.
[ Laughs ]
-All right. Luis?
All right, the question was --
I asked Lin, "What is your dad's
go-to karaoke song?"
-Well, it depends where in life.
You know, for a long time now,
it has been
"The Greatest Showman."
-[ Laughs ]
[ Ding! ]
-That's what he said.
He said,
it's "Greatest Showman."
You're a big
"Greatest Showman" fan.
I love that.
Hugh Jackman.
I love that you love that.
-I was gonna wear
my red jacket today.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my gosh.
[ Ding! ]
That's a double.
You get double points.
-Do I get an extra point
for that?
I told him, "He's got the red
jacket and everything."
-[ Laughs ]
-That's good.
He said the other one
could've been
"I've Had the Time of My Life."
-From "Dirty Dancing."
-♪ Time of my life ♪
Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-He said that played a lot.
-My wife always wanted to do the
jumping, and I would catch her.
-Yeah, I mean --
-Never happened.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you know.
You gotta have goals, right?
Okay.
Here we go.
Final round.
Lin, please mute yourself.
Wow.
He just took the headphones off.
There we go.
All right.
Luis, here's the question.
What is Lin's most embarrassing
childhood memory?
-He got summons
and sort of arrested
for singing in the subway
with friends,
collecting money,
while he was going to school.
-Wow.
I mean, yeah, it's trouble,
but I feel like he would
probably think that's cool.
But I will take that.
-That is not cool at all!
-No, it's not cool.
Do not get arrested.
-[ Laughs ]
But I feel like a little doo-wop
is kind of fun.
[ Laughs ]
-Not when the cops stop you.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true, yeah.
All right. Not cool.
Here we go.
Not cool.
Lin?
All right.
All right, here we go.
Can you hear us?
-I'm terrified
by the gesticulation I saw.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, the question was...
-Mm.
-..."What is your most
embarrassing childhood memory?"
-Oh, yeah, okay.
I have a couple of times.
There was a time I stepped
on ketchup packets deliberately
but covered
our assistant principal.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-We never heard of that.
-Yeah, I made --
I worked hard to make sure
you never heard about that.
-Your dad -- [ Laughs ]
Your dad's hearing about this
for the first time.
-Never heard of that!
But that was not cool.
-Poor Ms. Gemila.
[ Laughter ]
But, I mean,
I guess the other time was,
me and my doo-wop group got --
[ Laughs ]
Got stopped by the cops
for singing
Billy Joel in the subway.
[ Ding! ]
-That's it!
That's exactly right!
Come on!
-Is that really it?
-Yes, that was it!
That's what he said!
-Yeah.
I'm not embarrassed by that.
-That's what I said.
I said that sounds cool to me.
I would love to --
That sounds like --
Singing doo-wop in the --
-I was embarrassed
that the summons was way more
than we made
while we were panhandling.
-That's where you go
for the echo.
-I had to get a lawyer
to help them out.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
It might have been
more embarrassing for you
than it was for Lin.
-Probably, probably.
[ Laughter ]
-We got the score.
You guys are a match.
You're perfect father and son.
Congratulations.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much.
-You're welcome.
Give it up for Luis
and Lin-Manuel Miranda.
Their documentary
"Siempre, Luis"
premieres tonight on HBO.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
-I'm sorry about
the ketchup Ms. Gemila.
[ Laughter ]
-That was funny.